good morning John I live in a city that
most people would call a small town
there's all the montana has 70,000
people in it when the students are here
when they leave for the summer the
population declines significantly
somehow 70,000 people is considered to
be a small number of people it actually
is quite a large number of people but I
mean after all there are some cities
that have stadiums that hold more than
70,000 people so for some perspective
Missoula packs those 70,000 people into
2600 square miles
Manhattan has 22 times more people in 78
times less area and of course there are
many amazing things going on in
Manhattan it isn't just 1.3 million
people it's 1.3 million of the richest
most powerful most influential people on
the planet economic and cultural
creation on the scale of Renaissance
Italy and that is an interesting
comparison because Florence in 1500
contains some of the most powerful
economic and cultural forces the world
has ever known
Medici bankers Botticelli Machiavelli
Michelangelo da Vinci Brunelleschi
revolutionized the world from the seat
of the Renaissance in Florence Italy and
what was the population of Florence
Italy 1.3 million people no no millions
of people no hundreds of thousands of
people 70 thousand of course they were
tremendous political and economic and
cultural and historical forces that made
Florence the seed of the Renaissance but
one thing that I believe very deeply in
my heart and I think most historians
would agree with me is that it didn't
happen because there was just some
random collection of really great people
great people are everywhere all the time
it just so happens that only
occasionally our cultural and historical
and economic forces such that they will
be remembered for hundreds or even
thousands of years so I like to think of
Missoula as like a little Florence and
everybody walking around is an unnoticed
da Vinci and an unmade Machiavelli and I
think about what separates the great
people that I remember from the great
people that everyone remembers I think
it's a hundred percent circumstance
wanting a new channel this week with
Jessie Knudsen Castaneda and her husband
Augusto who you may know from their
frequent appearances on scishow they
bring to us animals that they have
rescued so that we can talk about them
in educate the world
that's Jessie's passion
that's her superpower Caitlin Hofmeister
who's also the producer of scishow is
going to be documenting the passion and
sweat and toil that it takes to run a
small business and feed hundreds of mal
two of those mouths happen to be twin
infant children now that I've produced
shows with a bunch of different
interesting people here in Missoula
Emily graslie and Lindsey doe and now
Jessie people have asked me why are
there so many interesting things going
on in this one little small town in
Missoula that's the thing though that's
the point there's interesting things
happening everywhere Susan a magical
place and they're not magical people
it's just people who have found
something that they're passionate about
but yeah that can be a hard thing to
come by I've watched everyone I've ever
known struggled with that trying to find
something that they believe is important
and I'm so grateful changing topics here
really fast that nerdfighteria has
provided that for me people talk about
all the things that I've been able to do
but it is only because I found something
here that I can believe in because yeah
I live in Missoula Montana but my first
allegiance is to this place a community
of hundreds of thousands of people with
shared ideas and values in interest in
Earth in Missoula and thus even more
full of unappreciated and unnoticed
DaVinci's and Machiavelli's and
Brunelleschi's the only difference
between something being vitally
important and not important at all is
whether or not you believe it is I
believe that this is important and that
is a gift that you have given me thank
you
John your life seems like a bit of a
grapefruit right now don't freak out and
stay sane and I'll see you on Tuesday if
you want to check out Jessi's new
channel there's a link in the
description and there's also if you
could just click over here if you're not
on your phone you can click on that with
your mouse but not on your phone or
doesn't work on phones